hi I'm Erik Bosse we got a new trailer
for Justice League in hits pack with
interesting subtle details and great
music choices and DC EU callbacks but
somehow still didn't give away any big
twist I for real when Clark said the
ring I have expected the camera to pan
over to Hal Jordan saying to me this
ring I'm gonna run through all the
things you might have missed and if
you're worried about knowing too much
about the plot some of my educated
guesses might accidentally become
spoilers my insight can be too powerful
sometimes you've been warned
let's get started
[Music]
I'll take that as a yes what the ring
Hey look Justice League is finally
showing a Superman in a trailer just
kiddin he's still dead this is a dream
and we're all crying now actually it's
interesting that this third trailer
began with Superman trailer one began
with Batman trailer to begin with one
woman so this third and probably final
trailer completes the DC Trinity you
probably noticed this reused shot of
Lois dropping soil on Clark's casket
from Batman vs Superman and Hans
Zimmer's amazing score from Manas field
[Music]
but the framing of these shots is also a
direct parallel to the first time lois
met Clark and Man of Steel Zack Snyder
even confirmed he's storyboarded the
scene with this in mind so the purpose
of this is to make this scene even more
dreamlike Lois is envisioning a future
with Clark that's really just a mirrored
version of her memory of their first
encounter also the choice to put Clark
and classic red flannel looks like an
homage to the 1978 Superman and maybe
this is just me but I feel like this
imagery of Lois walking out on this
front porch of a Midwestern farmhouse is
also meant to evoke that iconic shot
from Saving Private Ryan in both cases
the woman has gradually realized in the
worst possible news I don't like feeling
things let's move on Superman violence
acts of war and terrorism are all on the
rise I had a dream
it was the end of the world
okay so as Louis wakes up from her dream
and we get some audio and shots from the
last trailer we get this reaction shot
of kids actually think this could be
part of that robbery that we saw Wonder
Woman fight off last trailer and this
boy on the left seems pretty happy I
wonder why also in this section we see
some shots of the conflict between
Steppenwolf's forces and Amazonians and
I'm guessing this could be connected to
the part of movie where Steppenwolf
arrives and steals the mother box from
the mascara that we saw in the last
trailer by the way we now know that
Steppenwolf will be Darkseid's nephew in
this movie instead of his uncle like he
was in the comics I actually think in
this part of the trailer there mixing
shots from the earlier epic first
invasion attempt in the ancient times
with the Amazonians in the Atlantians
and man fighting against dark sides
parademon army and check out this shot
I'm guessing this guy is being
transformed into a parademon and yeah
this is all part of the fears that Bruce
and Diana are probably having for
Steppenwolf's new arrival the evil plan
being to terraform earth and transform
all of us into these para demons and
based off this guy's armor he kind of
looks like an ancient Roman soldier he
might also be an ancient blanton before
their kingdom would have sunk underwater
now a separate cut of the trailer
included different shots including this
one of an archer taking out a ship now
check out those glowing arms I feel like
this could be one of the gods maybe even
the archer goddess Artemis we actually
know she was planned to appear in
Justice League from those early set
visit and overall this notice what Bruce
says here I had a dream
and was the end of the world now Bruce
is probably referring to his nightmare
vision from Batman vs Superman the
apocalyptic future of a terraformed
earth filled with parademons and it
sounds like he and Diane are gonna
compare notes from past and future to
prepare for this threat let's move on
I think it's something more something
darker so in this section we start to
hear the amazing song choice for this
trailer a cover of David Bowie's heroes
by a gang of mutes
ever since Bowie's death in 2016 his
music has resonated even more powerfully
almost like he's inspiring us from
beyond the grave I think that makes
these lyrics so perfect for this trailer
with these people having to step up to
be heroes to carry the torch for their
fallen icon I also love this shot of a
girl seeing the swarm of parademons
coming out from this nuclear cooling
tower the scale of this shot frames this
swarm as if it was a swarm of locusts
which does give off this ominous
biblical tone with bruce's into the
world line from the port now I'm not
injecting random religious metaphors
here
I'm just taking zack snyder's cue from
the biblical references in Batman vs
Superman
The Devil's don't come from Hell beneath
us no no they come from the sky now Lex
is referring to Superman there but I
think his warning about Devils from the
sky later applies to the real threat in
the Bible a swarm of locusts was one of
the plagues of Egypt in the Old
Testament but also one of these signs of
the Apocalypse in the book of Revelation
I saw a star fallen from the heaven to
the earth to him was given the key to a
bottomless pit
yada then out of the smoke locusts came
upon the earth the shape of the locusts
was like horses prepared for battle not
trying to convert anyone I'm just saying
given Snyder's past allusions to
Christian symbolism I wouldn't be
surprised if there's a connection
between the biblical fallen star who
releases warrior locusts to end the
world and Steppenwolf and the pair of
demons who by the way come from a planet
called apocalypse ok Sunday school
dismissed let's move on
[Music]
we're asking people we done notaries
their lives that it's not saying it's
the opposite of what they're saying so
this section checks in with the
different Justice League members one a
woman is standing the top old Bailey
that's on the roof of the Central
Criminal Court in London it's a statue
of Lady Justice with the Lady of Justice
League yeah we get it now so like
cyborgs cat's cradle hollow display here
now if you look closely those are all
memories from his football days you can
also see his football trophies and
photos of them geared up behind them
actually kind of hope we see Bruce using
football analogies to try to convince
cyborg to be a team player okay imagine
this mother box is a football yeah screw
it I'm rich I play polo and I will say
this trailer did seem a bit more
lighthearted we got a few smiles out of
everyone and more banter between Bruce
and Aquaman it's the opposite of what
the saying is some of you have been
suggesting that this tone plus the
brighter color grading in this footage
is a result of Joss Whedon taking over
directing from Zack Snyder and turning
this previously dark film it is
something more like The Avengers now I
will admit that this joke does sound a
lot like Whedon sense of humor like you
could imagine Tony Stark saying this
line but at the same time it's not like
the earlier trailers with Snyder's
footage were totally without humor
just like a bat I dig it
may be temporary so I don't know I take
a flick on the cast at their word when
they said that the movie will be a blend
of Whedon and Snyder's voices rather
than one director saving the project
from the other and come on high hopes
for DC movies have never burned us
before right let's move on
divided we are not enough
[Music]
okay some interesting shots in this
section this footage of the Batmobile in
this major action sequence looks like it
now has these purplish colored rock
formations added to it and notice how a
lot of the shots shows these pieces
moving organically it looks like
wherever this is it is currently in the
process of getting terraformed there
also shots of Aquaman fighting
Steppenwolf underwater in Atlantis now
the extended cut of the trailer shows
more of this fight with Steppenwolf
chucking his battle-axe atom and more
clearly head-butting him into the pillar
and we get an even better look at
Steppenwolf's face in this one-on-one
fight with Wonder Woman I think the idea
here is that we're gonna see each of the
individual Justice League members fail
again Steppenwolf when they fight him in
single combat actually one woman
fighting Steppenwolf on this narrow
walkway reminded me a lot of Gandalf
fighting the Balrog and Lord of the
Rings Snyder has actually said that
Peter Jackson's visual choices were a
huge influence on him as the director
actually I'm surprised after seeing her
in the past couple movies that Diana
still has the scream you shall not pass
yet and then notice this shot of cyborg
the floor beneath him is the same
pattern as that shot of Steppenwolf
space last trailer where he kept the
mother box so here it looks like cyborg
is retrieving that mother box and I'm
guessing that since his cybernetic body
was created with the mother box maybe
he's the only one who can physically
move it alright let's move on
[Music]
made him a promise
that's why I brought you together
ride ain't over yet I love this section
we get this six stored Psalm flip from
Wonder Woman because I bend over and
reach down for a sword when he can do
this way faster and you get a great shot
for the trailer also notice the
background behind one woman at cyborg
that a frame pattern is the same in the
windows of Steppenwolf's base from last
trailer so rather than this being a
large spacecraft like we assumed before
I think this is actually just a
structure that's ground-based and look
at Steppenwolf as cyborg blasts off his
eyes are glowing blue the parademons
also have glowing eyes so maybe this is
a state he goes into when he's operating
the pair of demons like drones and then
we get this great shot of cyborg
catching Aquaman and for those of you
keeping track this is these second Rick
and Morty reference made in the Justice
League trailer mom made back in Barry
Allen's apartment the clip from Rick and
summers excellent give it to you revenge
training montage plays on one of the
screens so I think this clip completes
what looks like an amazing sequence with
Aquaman it starts with that leap off the
Batmobile in the first trailer then
moves on to this midair fight with
parademons a cyborg catching him here
and ends with that shot from trailer -
with him surfing on the parademons body
back down to the ground and yeah dude
you earn that hair flip okay let's move
on to the next section
[Music]
okay the only thing to point out here is
that this big sequence of off some full
team charge toward this warehouse
looking building now I'm not sure if
it's significant or it's something that
they're just blasting through to get
somewhere else but notice how it has
these cutout letters on the roof from
the reverse overhead angle it looks like
t OTG and earlier in the background you
can barely make out our OG o P and
combine all of that and it spells totes
Garo gob gibberish what am I doing with
my life let's just move on to the final
section please
okay this trailer ends with another
great fanboy moment from Barry Allen but
look closely at the Gotham City skyline
there now that's no Thoth Garo gap
that's ace chemicals the same chemical
processing plant where joker famously
fell into one of the many uncovered
chemical vats and discolored his skin in
harris also as seen in Suicide Squad the
same ace chemicals Joker Swan dove into
after doing the same to Harley Quinn ace
come on just put some lids on those bats
I just like the trailer included this
Easter Egg so it can be a nerd out
moment both for Barry Allen with the
bat-signal and for us nerds at home in
what ways do you think this trailer
looks different from the footage that
we've seen in previous trailers do you
think Joss Whedon is changing the tone
of the movie for the better and what new
character do you think Justice League is
still hiding from us obviously Superman
will be returning but who else should we
expect reen Lantern Shazam Darkseid
himself the rock as black Adam or maybe
that ace chemicals Easter Egg means the
Joker might drop in I don't know how
useful it will be against Steppenwolf
but it could be fun to see him and
Aquaman make fun of each other's tats
damaged really comment down below with
your predictions and thoughts on this
trailer and tweet me your thoughts
directly at EA vos or follow new rock
stars at new rock stars for updates on
her videos share this video and
subscribe the new rock stars for all of
our Justice League and deep sea deep
dives and if you really like this
channel you can become part of our team
by contributing to us on patreon
seriously this is ad nonsense from
YouTube has been unfairly targeting our
channel recently and we're
looking for ways to shift new rock stars
so that we're only responsible to you
guys and you can help us with patreon
big thanks to all of our donors
especially Alan Fleming okay thanks for
watching bye